the Gonzaga grad and Hall of Fame point
guard for the Utah Jazz where are you
right now John I'm still in Spokane
looking forward to an upcoming trip this
weekend the last time you played a
pickup games win Sunday okay where you
like playing a pickup game well there's
absolutely a no basketball player still
out there it's just an old guy running
around kind of barking at people the
hustle and run or things like that not
quite the same as the old days I'd say
how important was playing every game to
you I think you did it 213 times in your
career something like that you played
all 82 games
pretty much everything I mean it's it's
such a privilege I mean I I never took
one day for granted that was in there
there are people that go to watch
everybody I mean even if you're a backup
or there's people that go to watch and
see I think it's really important thing
to play every game and to to battle
through little injuries in order to do
so a lot of times from the age of 37 to
40 you started 328 out of 328 games how
many times were you questionable with an
injury during that period well who knows
what standard you're talking about I I
mean I don't think guys ever
questionable on any of those I'm sure I
sprained ankles and and you know had
little bruises and things like that but
for me it was never questionable and I
think the trainer's understood that and
the team understood that that they could
count on pretty much everybody on our
squad at those time to be ready to play
what do you think it'd be different now
with you and Karl with the games you
played and being smart with you know
Jerry Sloan would say let's limit your
minutes or let you sit out again I don't
know how that would have gone over with
you and Carl but we see that a little
bit more now what do you make of that
well car Jerry did limit us he limited
us in practice especially in the last
last couple years of our careers we
didn't practice a whole heck of a lot
grudgingly I mean we like to practice
that's part of the fun is going out
there with the fellows being part of the
team so even that we fought but any
limited minutes a lot more than Carl's
towards the end as well I just think
they felt Karl's body would hold up
of the my little body and so they
limited it they wanted us at the end of
the year they wanted us for more seasons
and I get that but I didn't enjoy it I
wanted to play every minute just kind of
as if it were a wrap ballgame when did
you know you could play at a high - well
I guess it went in stages the I was sure
the team the Jazz would want to cut me
after my first year I just thought that
I'd you know I'd hoped to fool in one
more year and maybe they'd give me
another try guess probably when when my
son my first contract after my rookie
year was at two and a half three years
into it that I felt I was going to be
there for a while but I never really was
comfortable comfortable with that I hey
I've made it it just never occurred to
me I always felt like I had to crawl and
climb a little bit but then you become
an all-star then all of a sudden like
something had to change
maybe confidence wealth leveled your
2526 and all of a sudden people go you
know this guy in Utah is you know
putting up a double-double here with
points and assists yeah I think I think
somewhere in there yet you you go wow
that people I am pretty good not half
bad but I should remember going into
every game thinking that guy that across
is across from me is better than I am
and I think that was maybe my approach
but I think it was an honest approach it
was how I felt how many scholarships did
you have I had three college three
Division One offers so Gonzaga
University of Montana and University of
Idaho Eastern Washington eventually
became Division one but at the time they
weren't and they offered me one as well
what was about Gonzaga I resisted
Gonzaga pretty pretty aggressively
I grew up basically on campus and snuck
into their gym I don't know thousand
times since I was six years old these
two dropped me down over the chain doors
because I could get in and I could sneak
in and open a window somewhere for my
older brother but so I I didn't really
it wasn't very appealing to me it was a
you know you want to get away from that
and yet at the end of the day when I
went on recruiting trips I wanted to be
home so I guess I'm a little bit of a
homebody mama's boy now your dad retired
he doesn't own the bar anymore that you
grow that they grew up with
no he doesn't know I'm Jack and dad's
anymore but he's but but we still
consider it home my old buddy Jeff
Condell who I played with in college
owns it long with Tim sorry Kevin
McDonald and it feels like home and it
acts like home it's still a place to be
I think you know when do you have your
first beer at 21 years old in jacket -
twenty-one well I might be fighting just
a little bit your kids might be
listening they'll use this against you
how tough is it when you're watching
your alma mater because I think they've
had cutaways of you in the stands and it
looks like you're more tense than you
were when you played I probably am
whether it's I mean it's a little bit
easier I don't David what was the last
one to play for the boys there and he
that was really nerve-racking now it's a
little bit less so but I still care
about these kids and certainly the
program and I guess I am a little
uptight watching it from up there's
nothing I can do to help I guess there's
fortunately nothing I can do to hurt
them either except for I'd stand out
there and hope they do well are you
going to Arizona and then staying if
they get to the championship game yeah
we're going to stay either way either
way it's again it's a it's the national
championship and we'll be down there so
we're really looking forward to the
weekend what's your favorite Michael
Jordan story I I think my favorite
Michael Jordan story had a it was one of
the events he's done since maybe it was
in a limp ik team reunion or something
being honored along those lines and
we're just sitting back in the green
room talking and I have half my family
if not my whole family sitting back
there and and just to watch him talking
and exchange stories with my kids I mean
he's a real person and he took the time
and it was you know was as if it was an
old college teammate of his he's talking
and sharing stuff and I just you know I
think that's the neat part it's always
to stuff behind the scenes that I enjoy
but did he mention then he finally admit
that he pushed off on Russell you know
we've argued about plays not just that
one but plays throughout our careers
that that we obviously disagree on but
and then that's always part of the fun
you bet those things get mentioned did
who talk more
bird you mean trash talk trash yeah I
wasn't around Larry as much I sure saw
it even as a rookie I came in he walked
into the gym and said coach I think I'm
told our whole team but to our coach
coach ah I'm gonna have 42 how many do
you have
he had 42 and then check himself out of
the game no way yeah I mean is for a
young player so he walks into the Utah
Jazz and just says to coach Sloan I
think I'm gonna put up 42 it was
actually Frank Layden that don't freak
out who did oh my gosh yeah and he did
it that's the kind of amazing part who
would be your MVP this year why I just
never liked the MV P SOT it's always
it's always the guy with the the biggest
stats I mean I think if you do that it'd
be tough to argue against Westbrook or
harden I mean wow just the stuff they
put up I think in the old days they kind
of picked from the the top team or the
top two teams and and maybe that gets
old so I don't know I try not to waste
too much time thinking about it's pretty
pretty small pretty small for me I think
but also looking at the point guard now
is the point guard evolving because it's
different than when you were playing or
Jason Kidd was playing it's you know in
what you're asked to do I mean this is
league wide where I call them point
guard because if they're scoring points
they're it's not running on offense as
much yeah there and there were guys like
that when I play to you I and I said
back then the so Hardaway everybody with
that Hardaway was like that yeah I'd say
so let me know yeah I go back through my
list and figure it out but there's a lot
of guys Kevin Johnson they could really
score the ball and did and look to score
first but every team has different needs
and I think they right now there's a
pattern as the point guards are bringing
it up scoring a lot of balls in their
hand a ton and and the but I always
think it's evolving it'll it'll change
next year because they won't be able to
find another Westbrook Butler that's
hard
would you be different now coming out of
college in what what your game would be
like oh good question you with the type
of influence that I've seen growing up
you didn't even play with the 3-point
line growing up yes oh yeah yeah I think
it would be different you come
and that you see that the only guys they
take are the ones that are taking 25
pretty shots a game if that's who you
want to be you're going to figure out a
way to take 25 or 30 shots a game the
Commissioner recently came out and said
that sooner rather than later thinks
there'll be a female head coach I know
Becky Hammon on the staff with the Spurs
Nancy Lieberman on the staff with the
Kings how do you think that that would
play out with players in the NBA I think
it'd be interesting I kind of like to
watch things like that to see how they
do play out I mean it's it would
certainly be different their experiences
as women growing up playing women's
basketball would be different than the
guys I don't think anybody could even
argue that and whether the guys would it
would would entertain that or not I
don't know I'd be fun to watch how would
you take that as a player if Pat Summitt
was all of a sudden your coach well you
picked Pat Summitt yet okay you'd go
wrong with her I mean [ __ ]
she's clearly proved herself in that and
she's quite a winner I you know I
believe coaching's about relationships
and if you can communicate with guys and
if you can I guess give orders without
feeling like you're barking at them and
bossing them I think anybody said could
succeed regardless of gender do you have
any of your short shorts left over yeah
yeah there they're probably in a drawer
the kids try to fish them out every once
a lot of a bag in the basement or
something and they don't even fit them
it's uh it's kind of funny but I don't
know if you've noticed short shorts are
coming back I know John I would love for
you know maybe maybe you could loan out
a pair of your short shorts for my
mancave here be kind of nice to put him
on TV here well the last pair I had
Bette was out I think shackle and it was
at the Olympics and he just would be
funny he tried to put on a pair and he
couldn't get it pulled up over one leg
so I say you ripped him no you didn't
quite rip my hair to wear on that
careful what's your favorite story from
the dream team oh because it sounds like
some guys had some fun I I don't know if
did you have fun oh absolutely I mean we
were sure we were treated like fight
like kings but it was kind of close we
had
we had armed we had armed motorcycles
escorting us everywhere we had
helicopters above snipers on the on the
on the hotels I guess my best story is
in the hotel again behind the scenes my
wife was out she crawled through the
window out onto this artificial deck it
was all you know between hotels between
buildings to hang the kids under wearing
pajamas up since that she had laundered
it that she'd washed herself in the sink
one night and while she was out there a
SWAT team repelled down from the top at
gunpoint held her at gunpoint thinking
she was a terrorist or something and
just hanging some kids underwear
wait John couldn't you send up for like
room service to have them do your
laundry uh who knows we like to do
things ourselves she took it upon
herself so I thought that was available
or not that's great hey congrats on the
success there with Gonzaga safe travels
and always always great to talk to you
John thank you thanks Dan great talk of
you all right John Stockton Hall of
Famer 10 time all-star now once those
guys start telling stories I don't even
know if they know how many great stories
they have but all of a sudden you know
you got people snipers rappelling down a
building to hold her at gunpoint think
that she's a terrorist there ma'am and
he was always fascinated I who never
ever asked for attention ever ever he
just played and it was almost a San
Antonio feel before San Antonio with him
now Karl Karl liked publicity he wanted
you to interview him John did not want
to be interviewed at all couldn't care
less I mean I'm here to play that's it
no fanfare when I retire I'm just going
to go and play and true to that that's
who he is
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience